pop jours j'avais aujourd'hui c'est un
grand jour
votre nouvelle émission gym tonic elle
veut plus longue avec plus de rythme des
musiques nouvelles
plus de gym de la dent et puis aussi un
clin d'oeil à vous nos petits amis
mais oui vous êtes tellement nombreux à
nous écrire que vous a fait une petite
parcelle de jeu où les lieux du jogging
puis aussi une petite chose formidable
qui veut dire qu'il faut que vous
restiez avec nous jusqu'à la fin
d'émission
car toutes les semaines on aura une
surprise pour vous voilà et on vous en
dit pas plus alors vous savez vous allez
avoir des courbatures vous savez bon
mais vous savez comme nous on en a aussi
alors ne vous inquiétez pas rester nous
fidèles puisque nous vous sommes fidèles
d'accord le cours est difficile vous
savez mais c'est pour ça des progrès
viennent vite
allez on va commencer
c
[Musique]
bon je passais toutes mes vacances vous
aussi ah bon vous êtes prêt maintenant à
l'herbe levé vous le matin cours va
commencer et vous savez vous ne pouvez
pas rater l'échauffement
c'est très important
[Musique]
cap sur un pied et solo
allez
laisse le temps de piquer mouvement
[Musique]
on change de pied un centre machine
mont joli pied
[Musique]
changer la pièce
m
[Musique]
non
oh
[Musique]
tous
le caliber et vous
google
[Musique]
je
enfin
[Musique]
m
mieux
têtu
[Musique]
pour
pas fier
[Musique]
les
m
les chiens
pour la tour
dans la tête
encore là
[Musique]
pire encore
ajournée
à lévis
[Musique]
changer de mains
je n'ai pas
[Musique]
non
j'attends
[Musique]
voilà allons souffler parle de se
retrouver avec autant de dynamisme
vous êtes bien chaud nous aussi bon
attention maintenant enchaînement
non-stop pendant 15 minutes
courage et amusez vous on s'assied les
points importants
le dos bien plat les épaules descendu
les gens très étiré la pointe de pieds
viennent allonger et on fait des
souplesses en avant sans brutalité 5 6 7
[Musique]
frans
ii et iii calm encore dan
quatre côtés de croix
[Musique]
k
l'abandon
[Musique]
donc là encore
n'est pas
m
son départ
[Musique]
non
ap
3-1
[Musique]
les bras
on
la perte est à eux trois
[Musique]
à l'avenir
bien sont plus dans la langue ses jambes
et on commet 6,8
[Musique]
4 on change de genre 4
qu'a changé
chan
[Musique]
on choisit
de plus
[Musique]
moi
et m
[Musique]
k
bravo reste debout
voilà en rien les épouses les épaules la
poitrine les brand l'eau du buste de
près
ces 6 7 8 4 changer de bras sans viande
rouge et encore
[Musique]
croire karine m
voir
comment quand même
3 carmen
[Musique]
tous
moi
[Musique]
kpmg temps
carney
[Musique]
ja m
suite
[Musique]
m
lot 3 4 bravo et on fait ce soir
d'accord précipitent pas pour longtemps
on souffle dans les pieds on allonge de
rang
[Musique]
trois quarts
lee
[Musique]
oh
au près 6
[Musique]
c'est pas comme alès
non
[Musique]
allez
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est satan
m
oui
[Musique]
non
oh
on voit la fin 2001
[Musique]
et
mais
[Musique]
lâchez tout nous enchaîne sa davillars
aller au boulot sur une banda c'est
amusant de le faire
[Musique]
m
[Applaudissements]
trois chats
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pas là
paris
voilà
m
[Musique]
ana
atta
papa
ils permettront demain ouais stop bien
soufflé respirer
[Musique]
maintenant nous allons ouvrir pour vous
notre séquence espace qu'est ce que
c'est que l'espace l'espace c'est
oublier un peu la gym pour rentrer dans
la danse
car on avait très envie vous veniez
danser avec nous
alors aujourd'hui sont là pascal qui va
être un petit peu votre délégué voilà
elle va apprendre en même temps que vous
les mouvements parce que pas question
vous restez assis à regarder vous le
faites avec nous ça va pascal tu te sens
bien
oui alors regarde on se place en sixième
position
sixième position pour vous sont les
pieds joints on va aller sur le côté on
déplace le poids de son corps sur le
côté on va étirer le bras et allonger le
buste allonge allonge allonge mais ne
montrent pas ton épaule des santons
épaules voilà ensuite on se détourne de
profil allez-y faites le en même temps
que nous non il faut que tu fasses
passer le poids ton corps sur ta jambe
de devant voilà
et bien ici le pied sur demi pointes
ok on lève un bras
et puis l'autre pas en arrière le bras
encore encore et la quatrième fois les
deux bras en l'air d'accord c'est pas
trop difficile on continue on se
détourne en plis mais attention c'est
pas la peine de plier à fond et d'avoir
les fesses sortie ou le ventre en avant
on clique droit les genoux sur le côté
voilà et on repart sur le côté hans et
iront ces tirs se braquer contre la
cuisse
on se détourne encore une fois de bras
en avant non pascal le poids de ton
corps sur ta jambe
voilà maintenant va plier la jambe de
derrière khlie en retirant un bras voilà
les y pousser voilà est en balance son
bras comme un balancier 3,4 on se
replace
alors je viens tu es genou reste très
droit et maintenant refait la même chose
de l'autre côté
alors on y va si je me recule un peu
reste bien devant tu as un miroir pascal
certain regard de toi comme ça tu peux
te corriger oui détourne toit de l'autre
côté on se grandit poids du corps bien
sûr la jambe devant n'oubliez pas ça toi
non plus on balance ses bras trois fois
quatrième fois les deux on plie oui on
va bien sur le côté et tirez vous ah non
je vois regarder ce que vous faites vous
plier et vous décaler ce mouvement qui
doit rester vous devez être bien entre
vos jambes
c'est seulement le bus qui travaillent
décembre encore davantage son bus pascal
voilà on se re détourne
on se grandit poids du corps ok et ampli
est en balance la tête peut suivre c'est
pas une obligation et on se replace et
ainsi de suite ce sont des mouvements
que vous allez enchaîner continuellement
comme ça vous êtes vraiment sûr d'y
arriver
7 8 3 talent iii tout la terre
[Musique]
carmine
il
[Musique]
après
noah
[Musique]
camille et oies
ja
[Musique]
non
[Applaudissements]
m
un mot
[Musique]
car
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
4 m3
[Applaudissements]
on
[Musique]
k
m
[Musique]
la frêle
je
[Musique]
m
1 4 et 1 2 voilà maintenant on va
s'amuser c'est la séquence jogging mais
avec des jeux toutes les semaines on
aura un nouveau thème
c'est aussi un clin d'oeil pour qu'ils
devinent art pour tous nos petits amis
qui nous regardent et qui nous écrivent
si souvent alors le jeu attention c'est
pour tout le monde mais pour vous les
petits alors regardez ici j'ai un ballon
mettez votre bras comme moi voilà tenait
bien le ballon
maintenant je prends le ballon et on va
s'amuser ensemble je vais vous lancez
vous allez me l'envoyer regardez je fais
une répétition et davina regardez bien
davina je t'envoie mon ballon tu es
prête oui attention car je vous le lance
attention ça fait mal si vous le prenez
la et il ya un effort musculaire on
s'amuse mais vous avez assez fort mais
là vous êtes prêts attention le voile a
envoyé le mois et bravo alors maintenant
j'amuse tous ensemble avec notre ballon
on va taper le ballon par terre on va
faire plein de choses
vous êtes prêts on tape la balle on est
devant aller tous ensemble
allez venez oui taper le ballon ovale
[Musique]
encore attention
entre en vigueur
[Musique]
on est à 8
pliez pas de respirer
[Musique]
allez allez vous vous passerez en garde
ces panneaux
[Musique]
je regarde
s'attendre avec la relaxation sous les
mers
[Musique]
respirer
bon
m
[Applaudissements]
beaucoup
à
oh
ans
[Musique]
oh
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bon
com
que
[Musique]
e
à
on
eh bien écoutez bravo parce que c'était
une reprise et nouvelle serre et
j'espère vous avez bien bien suivi vous
n'êtes pas trop fatigué que vous êtes
bien amusés à la semaine prochaine ne
nous oubliez pas pendant la semaine
mais maintenant la surprise attention
c'est pas terminé on vous emmène avec
nous alors venez suivez nous je crois
que là surprise on l'a déjà on regarde
leurs efforts le poignet droit le coude
sur le comptoir penche la tête pourquoi
renverser la famille joue la tension
paris le mali plancher loupé la messe
sait rien des mouchoirs empêcher que je
m'emballe s y va la télé et ou bleu
poster tombe à pic soudain binhai
merlini est aussitôt cette démence est
projeté mourir en entrant se fait
maintenant à moi quel mur au champ
établi dans la rue alors moi
polyphonique et me suis tourisme
[Musique]
je mets un glaçon et toi je versais la
boisson et caniveaux
[Musique]
la caroline
grand sportif
oui on a plusieurs recours à notre actif
on en a principalement je suis assez
fier c'est que tous les trois on peut
plonger en même temps dans une piscine
sans faire d'éclat bourassa ce qui est
assez rare ouais
et puis il est évident que quand on
regarde ces deux individus on se rend
compte tout de suite on avait tendance à
travailler plutôt le haut
oui voilà t'as pas une petite question
d'avinash posée j'ai une question à vous
poser mais qu'est-ce que vous pratiquez
le plus l'aérobic où l'apéro big c
l'aérobic willem et oui c'est un peu les
deux c'est une très bonne question et si
simple que ça ne paraît ça demande de la
concentration ça demande un bon coup
d'oeil du sang froid
l'apéro bic a oui mais c'est le contrôle
permanent évidemment le bar étant à peu
près cette distance de voix timbrée il
faut même le moins qui laisse encore
mais ça c'est un de vos secrets mais
alors et un autre un hôte de secret de
votre forme éblouissante éternelle
jeunesse difficile tenue du dos oui
c'est un vertueux qui est soudé non vous
savez on va essayer d'être un gramme
sérieux est-ce que vous avez pour les
téléspectateurs un petit truc parce que
j'ai quand même une forme olympique vous
sentez cette s'en sont merveilleusement
bien mais il ya je vais te donner
l'emploi du temps des prochains jours il
km par semaine
voilà par exemple prenez-vous de paille
aussi bonne au ghana par exemple demain
qu'est ce qu'on fait de maman prend la
voiture demain vers 8 heures et on
descend jusqu où je te le demande en
mille et un limousin prime manière si ce
n est une ville aux alors successivement
fait un match mal à mâcon chalon d'année
l'annoncé grain de mil ailleurs
commence-t-on à droite par dans votre
sens évidemment comme
il faut changer immédiatement on va sur
sierre hier la montagne la part des
liquettes de limoux qui alarme fait mon
boulot c'est formidable quel est votre
truc auprès de ruch un truc pour être en
forme mais ça faire ces régions par
exemple à sancerre bon ça va c'est
toujours la même finalement vous avez
compris voilà safari ça dépend c'était
oui c'est ça ouais mais avec du verre
plat bon maintenant je pense que puisque
vous n'êtes pas nous révéler votre truc
nous on va en révéler un petit truc
d'énergie c'est qu'il faut faire
provision un maximum de son énergie pour
pouvoir la dépense et au moment où on
veut et pas n'importe comment dans la
journée à tort et à travers alors voilà
c'est ce que je voulais que tu nous
dises aucun ont conclu
merci qui merci les charlots
[Musique]